do not attempt the techniques you are
about to see without consulting a
professional
on this episode of the dog whisperer the
first time i encountered eco he was
outside
i thought he was cute as soon as she let
him in he attacked
he thinks he's the man of the house
she likes to lunge at bicyclists
children
homeless people in wheelchairs
because they don't see legs an actual
reaction is they put a hand out
she would get upset and it's getting
worse
when good dogs go bad there's one man
who's their best friend caesar milan
no dog is too much for me to handle
i rehabilitate dogs yes i train people
i am the dog whisperer
i really didn't understand what it must
be like for parents
of physically challenged children what
they must feel
and in a small way we kind of see that
with binky
and it's opened my eyes
two-year-old chihuahua mix binky is part
of a loving family that includes two
cats
a chihuahua terrier mix named sparky and
two humans
john and sylvie forrest pinkie has a
last name
which is larue which means the street in
french
because she was homeless on enough for a
year and a half
where she had different shelter a rescue
he wants work
we decided that we didn't want sparky
getting old and not having a friend
and i went to the dog park one day
and someone told me about her they said
the lady over there has a dog that
doesn't have front legs and i thought
oh her eyes were speaking to me
so i came home and i told john and he
said
i always wanted a dog with two legs
so i was like well she's at the dog park
she seems to really love to hop i don't
think that
she thinks that she has any limitations
we decided to bring her home then we
just put her down on the floor and she
just started picking up toys
and sparky just let her do what she was
doing without growling at her which is
very unusual for sparky
although people tend to fall in love
with binky the feeling isn't mutual
it's okay when people would get too
close she would get upset
because they don't see legs they just
want to be nice to her and natural
reaction is they put their hand out
my greatest fear about binky is
potentially biting somebody
but a lot of people seem to be willing
to take that risk too it's a little
unusual
and somehow it's not getting better it's
getting worse
the additional challenge of trying to
provide for a two-legged dog appeals to
john's creative nature
i see something and i want to make it
better with binky it was natural for me
to
think of something to make for her john
invented special vehicles with the hope
they would make binky more mobile
i think binky wants to run john and i
don't think that binky should be
confined to a pouch
or walking on concrete which is really
bad for her chest
so john's made actually three different
contraptions
mechanically the wheeled wonders work
but binky refuses to get rolling
so i made it and uh she was afraid of it
and i committed i'm just not going to
give up
act like you want to walk binky looks
like she's taking a nap actually on the
little contraption
and she doesn't want to move her legs i
would love for seizure to tell us
first of all what's wrong with what
we're doing with the contraptions
and also stop her from being so
aggressive with people
i wouldn't say that i feel sorry for
binky ever
i just feel bad sometimes if i think
she's in a situation that needs help
caesar has worked with many physically
challenged dogs
and he believes they don't perceive
their own disabilities the way that
humans do
now can she walk she hops like a rock
okay good yeah i missed i met one of
those like this does that happen
when we're out and about uh sylvie might
carry her in a pouch
or i'll carry her in my arm and people
will want to pet her
and she'll get a little aggressive why
not we're not certain if she'll bite
them or not but i think it's come pretty
close
right i think she's just afraid because
she is not sure
my job as a dog lover as well
knowledgeable dog lover is no touch no
talking
eye contact okay that's the best way for
anybody to acknowledge her presence
if if i do let's see start looking at
her leg because that's what your eyes
are gonna bring you
to it then she said something wrong ah
which is what everyone does yeah they
just come on yeah oh my god
sorry what happened nothing wrong with
me and there is not yet i drink water i
eat food i breathe i poop i do
everything so nothing wrong with me
right nothing no no no they're not
mentally disabled right mm-hmm we make
them disabled
even though you're trying to give
affection it's a negative energy
mixed with love right so here's a little
bit of poison
with a little bit of sugar yeah yeah
yeah animals will pick up on the
negative energy yeah okay
the sugar is not as strong wow now we
have a question about he made two
contraptions for her so she could
walk or run and she's afraid of
so them but she's working perfectly fine
into legs yeah
and how long can she walk she can go on
forever yeah we would have to stop her
so that she doesn't get too sore you
know so what part are you i'm gonna help
you with
whether or not it's it's worth trying to
get her
mobile mobile meaning more mobile more
mobile where
she could actually push herself and um
not bounce on her chest as much so that
she could maybe go a whole block or she
can do both
yeah that was the idea i don't think she
understands what it's for that's what i
always say
yeah because she sits there and she
turns the head sideways and the legs
just don't move
so the first time you introduce her to
that how was the intro
how was the ritual how was it i don't
know it's probably completely wrong
right it was and everybody was like it's
going to be great
i said and you know what maybe it was me
you know because it's
i know that i mean i know i'm going to
have a lot to pay today
you know so my attentions are good right
about it we get stressed so
so we don't want to put her in it right
yeah he starts stressing him you give
the wrong meaning to something so great
and then people ask us how is it going
and usually i say not good who feels
worse he does
he does okay so can we you and i do it
together yes
okay and then you wait yeah okay you
understand why right sure yeah
because your energy will overpower us oh
sure no it's okay
i want to see with my own eyes how does
dog feel about the outside world so i
can make a true evaluation
is she exploring like a normal dog is
she hesitant is she nervous yeah sparky
whoa she drums she's incredible
and so tell me about this one okay
that's sparky they get along well
yeah and she doesn't feel sorry for her
she doesn't yeah
no there's no such a thing see a lot of
times the lessons are right in front of
us you know like the dogs give us
lessons but we don't see it no
because we're so caught up on being
human so you don't really have an
aggressive case
come on up up good nice
like that so i have two goals one was to
make binky comfortable with all these
inventions created by their owner who
loves them very much
second was making sure the human
understand the feeling sorry is not
gonna create
any positive outcome
oh i love this one isn't that pretty
first caesar wants mickey to become more
comfortable in the harness that will
hold her in the wheelchair
he entices binky with food to help make
this a positive experience
this is very very important for you to
see that the brain is not nervous if the
brain is nervous so fearful they won't
take food now take it off
there you go you see it right after
she gets it now put it on again yep
so i bring it let the nose follow
then i don't just bring it put it in her
mouth i let her
follow because nose is the most powerful
sense they have
yeah you want the nose to be connected
to the exercise
okay so the nose the eyes and the brain
are going to do the exercise
there you go she's coming through the
foot okay so put the next step on it
hold on click food yeah then it's the
next
feeling the tightness food yeah
there we go at that moment just let it
go oh it's okay all right
now she can walk around with that freak
you know and and experiment
before you put it into the next object
we don't know how long is it gonna take
so we're not gonna put time into it but
that's okay
that's great yeah we kept thinking well
we did 10 minutes of training it's not
working
kind of giving up and not realizing that
it's going to take a lot longer than
that
when dog whisperer continues can binky
make one small step for men
two-year-old binky was born with just
two legs but still manages to get around
a bit
her owners john and sylvie forrest plan
to make binky more mobile
but the chihuahua terrier mix seems
frightened by the devices
and refuses to move one inch when placed
inside them
after binky spends almost 20 minutes
wearing the harness
caesar leads everyone outside for the
next step what we want to see is that
she's comfortable with the harness even
in this side of your house
let's go for work
what we're trying to do here is for her
to move with the harness on
yes before we put it on the car okay
yeah there we go oh that's good there we
go and that's really the motion we want
in the card
yeah where she pushes herself with the
back legs that's right it's all making
sense
now we're gonna do it a little bit more
difficult for her
not so she tells you right away when
that thing is around this is how i feel
okay i know that look yes i felt like
i'm in the way good job man and so
i i'll do anything you know whatever i
can do to
enable her to you know be free or walk
so i got the heck out of there john is a
good example today
of a man who was not um
afraid to show weakness yes he had a
little trouble in the beginning
but then he said you know what i'm doing
this for binky i'm fine
so we're asking her to get close to the
object now the object if you get close
to it you get food
then you place her in there just for a
little while okay yeah
i'm taking this one
so right now she's doing exactly what
you say normally when we put this thing
on this is what she does
if she takes one we remove the object
not taking it sometimes what what
happens is they don't want that same
scent that's why you have to bring
like a different scent okay i'll give
her lettuce she likes tomatoes
she likes bananas bananas
all right there's some meat too if she
wants this she likes this meat
she's gonna be full i i feel like
benihanas
chop chop there you go someday we remove
the object
and reward
oh and that's delicious so what she's
really getting is that object gives her
food
yeah you understand yes it's it's so
making sense yes
so it doesn't mean she's gonna go onto a
walk right away
caesar switches places with sylvie so he
can use her affection as binky's reward
for getting hooked up to the device
legs here watch this so
there you go so and see there you go
see it there we go
you saw how i set her up to go in there
and then i remove her
bring it back okay so she was facing
this way
and i keep moving her moving her into
she find no choice just to go in there
face the right way yeah okay and then
she faced the right way
i let her relax a little bit then i
remove her so i answer
it so they're gonna ask you so what do
you want i want you to go in there
and so what are you gonna give me after
that then after you relax
i took you away you give and take it's
not such a thing as you just give
give and not take there you go
that's good you see it that is good
see so you become the carrot the banana
and all that stuff
yeah see what i mean you don't always
have to use food and the person who's
you know helping here
intensifies the relaxation about being
in there so now we are we're
conditioning the brain that if she goes
in there she receives affection
another positive experience oh it hooks
up right now yeah
hook it up yeah let me do it i'll do it
for you okay
this is team work by the way okay
teamwork is good steamwork is great
she's standing up on her hind legs she's
never done it once she's not afraid
right now that was the best you've done
yes yeah
nah
i was so excited i just wanted to grab
her and bite her
like a dog your turn
look she already did it we're leaving on
a high note here that is a high yeah
high note is when you
die i saw two different guys and one
body the guy who wanted to do
this wonderful thing and then the guy
who hesitated for doing it
and of course my goal is to bring the
best out of people
this transformation is real once you do
it yourself
i am your treat see if you can be in
front and yeah
and um yeah thank you
thank you come here be come over
come on dear let's go just one step
come on you can do it
she's gonna do it i can tell look at
that
hi binky it's so nice to see you like
that
yeah you wanna come there you go
there you go there you go that's great
i got more than what i asked you know i
got like four steps
i am your reward here we go binky was
never mentally or physically challenged
she was just misunderstood
you know she saw the harness in the
wheelchair as a positive thing
it's just a matter of consistency
practicing it over and over
wow do you how powerful energy is
i don't know who's gone through more her
or me
i thought that's the excitement
everybody gave me while i was
fabricating these different wheelchairs
she has so much support and i was just
reluctant to be as excited as they were
and i have to work on that
i love days like this you know we took
our time today yeah but tomorrow should
be
shorter and shorter and shorter and
shorter when you see a dog in two legs
don't feel sorry just clap
cause that dog is still alive so yeah so
you just clap and that energy
transferred to them thank you guys it
was a pleasure
thanks bye okay vicky
there goes your hero
next when a canine goes ballistic at
camp pendleton
the marines call in reinforcements dog
boot camp expert cesar milan
camp pendleton near oceanside california
is the primary west coast base of the
united states marines
here recruits train to fight and win
battles wherever they occur
but marine gunnery sergeant tessie
madero and her sister brasil
weren't expecting to confront an enemy
within
i've had kiko for seven years it was
late at night and i remember
my dad put something on my back and i
turned around like what is this and i
saw it was my dog and he was just
jumping on me and
you know from then on it was like that
was my little baby
he's very affectionate he loves to just
snuggle
and he just loves to feel like he's with
you next to you
after priscilla and kiko moved on to the
base to live with tessie and her
rottweiler brandy
kiko immediately took over barking
commands at everyone
he's just aggressive he thinks he's the
man of the house
when friends come over he really doesn't
like it
one of my sister's friends when he put
his hand down piko bit him in his finger
gunnery sergeant angela mclaurin refuses
to visit unless kiko is confined to his
quarters
i remember the first time i encountered
kiko he was outside i thought he was
cute
as soon as she let him in he attack
before i even come i call and dare put
them up because i don't go in that she's
put up
he also takes things from the garbage
and once
i try to take it from him he'll try to
bite me
no no no if you get a broom
he'll attack the broom no no no
no when he realizes that someone is
leaving then he'll throw a
i believe that he does have some sort of
separation anxiety
angela and brazil prepare for hostile
action every time they get ready to
leave the house
when he sees that i'm trying to put
brandy in the garage
he acts up he just doesn't want to get
into the garage he hates it
we have to grab sandwich meats throw it
in the garage
and corner him in after kiko started
chewing through the door frame as part
of an escape attempt
they blocked the doorway with a piece of
large particle board
the dogs just made a party out of it
they just broke it to pieces
also we bought this big huge metal sheet
and still he actually climbs on top of
another shelf and he's still eating up
the doorway area he's determined to get
out
i hope that caesar can help my dog be a
bigger part of our lives where he
doesn't have to be secluded because of
his behavior i want him to
be able to enjoy his life with us and we
can all just be together
it's getting pretty bad kiku is ruling
the house kiko is
the marines call in caesar milan in
hopes that he can defuse kiko's
aggression
it sounds to me like kiko is the pack
leader of this household
i guess right have you tried to
discipline this dog
yes i have and what approach have you
used you have to get like long objects
because he'll he'll bite back so um
there's this like that type of thing
you know and then i'll show it to him
and he'll he'll bite at
it as well but he'll stay away from it
but i know that that's not the right
thing to do
so your energy and body language should
be enough
yes yes it should be just like here in
the military it's energy and
they're not carrying you know exactly
you know that that person is uh
whatever rank he has and but
like when he does see that we're being
stern with him is
he gets more bold it was obvious to me
that pretty much in every single area
kiko was in control
of the situation so you love him
obviously
right but you're afraid of him i'm
afraid he'll bite me and attack me it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter the
thing is you are afraid
and that's what he sees he doesn't know
where it comes from
or why they don't do the rational thing
they just know you
are fear what he definitely needs is
somebody who
who can convince him to become
submissive
that's all it is does your energy have
to be stronger than his energy
so do you walk with kiko uh we try to
walk him as much as we can
but monday through friday we usually are
at work or school so the weekdays is a
little bit harder
it blows my mind that we are in a place
where the spirit is about being
physically and mentally
in shape to follow a structure to follow
authority figure
but at the same time they're not sharing
that concept with their dogs
to be a team i mean marines stands for
that
all right let's meet this guy who's
creating trouble in in this
marine base did you believe this
who knows what happens coming up it's
caesar versus kiko in a battle of wills
kiko rules the camp pendleton home of
marine gunnery sergeant tessie madero
and her sister priscille but caesar
plans to retake command of the home
front
oh my god is this kind of guy
okay hear the bar see that bark
is insecurity we're going to take
advantage of that
this is more psychological than anything
else
i'm just blocking him i'm becoming i'm
becoming the medal
knowing the kiko is gonna control you
he's gonna make you part of his kingdom
i have to come in and present myself as
an authority figure
because the dog is so small and quick
caesar uses his foot to block kiko's
attacks
at that time it was definitely a battle
it was definitely
two dominant males going out at each
other
suddenly caesar gets some unexpected
backup
brandy so that this doe was italian
human and
in her belief we don't attack humans
very
all right very good so the raw dweller
support me
as a team see i'm using the i'm using
the rod wire to help
now he sees two against against one
there you go
see that's why it's very important to
understand hack pack concept
you have to understand pack concept
because i use her
to help me to block this dog so it was
two against one
see that's better he's already putting
his ears back
his head low his tail is now between the
legs
i put a leash on him but at the same
time he just didn't know how to
surrender
well the ratty is trying to help again
in this but now the dog is under stress
so we don't
egg
there you go now i take care of it
for seven years this guy did not
surrender to anybody everybody
surrendered to him
it's gonna drain a little bit more hey
so i waited for the right time so i can
grab
there you go like a snake there you go
so after i grab i put my finger close to
the jaw
i put them in the ground and then help
him to relax
there you go there you go
that is submission now i'm gonna move
so he can get up and then i'm gonna come
back there we go
the brain was not gonna strike me
anymore the brain surrendered to me
i was the general you know i i was the
one in charge he was saluting me
are we gonna give affection this dog has
received
a lot of affection i'm pretty sure at
the wrong time
he has received the wrong discipline
next caesar gives brazil and tessie some
basic training
on how to drain some of kiko's energy
with a treadmill
fighting part of it absolutely typical
he's fighting and he's trying to run
away from the situation you have to see
that you
you can't give up every time he goes
back he corrects
himself there you go you put it right
back the only choice right now is for
him to stay there
again like a military thing it doesn't
matter what happens around you got to
stay focused
that's another way for you to burn
energy when you have no time to
exercise it there you go
this is a 360 turnaround never in my
mind when i thought he would be doing
this
hey for the next exercise
caesar shows the women how to retake
command of kiko inside the house
go it was obvious to me between tessie
and brazil that the most softer energy
was brazil
pico no no no name oh brazil was being
frustrated fearful intense so this is
how my friend kiko will view her so i
needed to
uh to push brazil to do it and to pay
attention
go just put more
assertive energy there was way too calm
hey look not even touching
right there's more energy in body
language sending him to a place
so you're coming and pushing and that
you know triggers this it took a while i
took repetition i'll try one more time
yes thank you kiko he can put up a
really
hard fight at times i learned to take
control and
you know show your dog that you are the
leader there we go
hi come in after achieving victory at
the front door
they head to the next battleground the
garage door
all right so let's invite them inside
the garage then you're gonna ask them to
stay there with the door open
okay
stay go back this is just like the
treadmill exercise you gotta stay there
until we say so
you pretty much have to become like this
thing you know as
you're not allowing them to come out so
let's walk this way ladies a lot of
times people use
food to encourage a dog to go in a place
but they're not
convincing the dog to stay calm
submissive they're just trapping
and so this feeling of being behind
walls
it was not a pleasant feeling go
notice that i'm not going in there with
them they have to go
in there i'm just saying go in there
right there now my goal is for him to
totally surrender
right and and stop coming in and that's
how you end the exercise that's how you
know the guy you got it
go back stay stay
so make it clear you know just make it
clear
even if he does it a hundred times i
myself rather spend
repetitions that's when you truly love
your dog
you know when you stay there until he
gets it
go
so it's really about staying consistent
there you go that's better
right can you see the can you see it i
mean he's definitely surrendering to the
idea of door open you guys over here
looking
there you go that's better that's better
he actually made them stay in the garage
without closing the metal sheet
that was amazing to me because that's
most of the stress in
my morning is taking them into the
garage and locking them up i have to
wake up a lot earlier to do this
oh you guys can do it in the afternoon
because it really takes
time right to practice something like
this in the end of the day that's what
it is
time we need time to actually put all
these concepts and all these exercises
into action and not just
you know waste that time doing nothing
let's go for a walk
before he leaves caesar requires kiko to
pass one more test with gunnery sergeant
mclaren
they told me he hates her
i don't believe the animals hate you i i
think
hate is more a human behavior and if
they practice exercise and discipline
the dog changes state of mind we're
coming to you just don't move
just for your experiences it's really
about just being you don't even have to
pet him
it's just for you to accept him being in
the space you know
right now it begins just by being close
to each other so you have to relax
i know you don't try but trust the
handler trust the handler come on trust
the handler okay
okay let me see if you let me touch me
no no it's not about touching him i
don't want to touch him though i never
did
oh you just relax then let him come to
you
there we go don't touch just let him
come to you
i'll pay you money i've never done that
that's cool
give me my money that's cool
wanna do it again yes angie was amazed
she believed that caesar was not gonna
change kiko at all
she believed this was gonna be his first
failure let's go kiko it was great
you know that's all i ever want to do is
just really touch him because i love
dogs
and it's the first one that never really
you know approached me in this way
see he's being social right now
everybody pretty much he wants to meet
everybody so far
in this particular case we needed to go
all the way
back to the foundation of relationship
and fulfillment
once you share fulfillment and develop
relationship what you get is stress and
respect
that looks like a totally different dog
i know
this is what we see on tv and we say oh
yeah they just cut everything or
whatever
you bet my friend i give you affection
too
very good you're a cool guy
misunderstood that's all it was kind of
like i had to step out of the box today
and i saw all the things i was doing
wrong and
a lot of it made a huge difference in
just one day
it's like a completely different geeko
me and my sister has to work as a team
and just keep up with it day-to-day
we'll motivate each other it's just
gonna take some time
from our busy schedule you like that
next two spoiled divas call all the
shots for hollywood director mike
you are watching nacho wild sit and stay
remain calm and submissive until we come
back
and action oh no mommy's late mommy's
late
you be good be good be good mommy's late
for work
writer and actor mike white made his
directing debut with the feature film
comedy
ear of the dog off the set
mike wrestles daily with two
temperamental performers who run his
home
french bulldogs tootsie and ginger a
little bit of turkey
ginger i mean i was you know a single
guy who had not had a lot of
responsibility and suddenly taking on
two dogs it's a huge
undertaking and these dogs like are a
full-time
gig fast
i mean they call french bulldogs the
clown dogs
they're just like clowny buffoonish
absurd
looking dogs titsy just always looks
like
you know a child who thinks their parent
is about to leave for
a dinner party and she just has this
abject look on her face
don't go don't go please don't go
and then i have ginger who is up to no
good she always is looking at me out of
one
corner of her eye what what do you want
what did i do
ginger ginger ginger's a little bit
willful and mischievous
she is always trying to eat the cat food
no ginger
no that's the kitty's food
the more mike's film career consumes his
time the more the dogs consume his house
so they've gone through like dining room
tables dining room chair anything with
wood
they chew remote controls they also chew
my phones i have no home phone anymore
because all of the phones have been
chewed up
and uh so i just use my cell phone
tootsie is a very like high-strung dog
like on watts she's a handful she likes
to lunge at
bicyclists and children and like
homeless people in wheelchairs
and ginger's the opposite she likes to
just flop down in the middle of the road
and not move if she thinks she's coming
back from a walk
come on ginger ginger
they're just a handful
there's a lot of things that i can't do
because i just can't seem to manage them
and because i love them so much and want
to be able to you know
incorporate them as much into my life as
i can i'd like to be able to figure out
how to like
uh fix some of their bad behavior
right you frog dog caesar arrival take
one
agreeing to take a role in this domestic
drama caesar plays the part of the dog
behavior expert
i mean basically it comes down to they
just don't listen to me
yeah like i guess i'm a bad
disciplinarian
okay i mean i don't guess i know i am
that's very nice
but you're a director in it right yeah
you have a pack of people
yeah i should be able to see if they
make mistakes right they become afraid
they don't do what you say yeah what did
you do
well usually i try to hire people who do
their job because i'm
good at the reward side i'm not good at
the punishment side i'm not a good
disciplinarian
see i don't practice discipline from a
punishment right
because punishment most of the time has
the energy of being frustrated or angry
yeah but you don't want to be related
right
right you know so he rather not do it
because he doesn't want to be seen as a
bad
human being which is it a
misunderstanding of what true leadership
is all about
it's a choice i think you choose the
okay i just rather work with
happy-go-lucky people who just do their
thing
so i don't have to bring this side of me
right
so i guess we gotta find something that
motivates that side of you
ginger she's eating the cat food go
ahead man do your thing
let me see you ginger no
get out of there that's for the kitty
this is the second can of cat food she
ate today
you bad dog yeah let's see how it what a
good disappointment
well you did 50 good and then the other
50 you went into
your normal sale so what you need to
change
is the energy that is coming from the
inside out so you're being taken more
seriously
do you have like a person that you feel
that that person is assertive
anybody that you like the stands tall
hit up right and feels that he can
conquer the world right
you know how james bond is though is
right right right john wayne is another
man you you name it face
out any al pacino
michael corleone from the godfather al
pacino there you go
he's a certain that's red song those
people will kill you
gandhi he was pretty assertive
he was calm he was calm submissive which
in the animal world that is not
leadership
no no no no so something between gandhi
and scarface yes
i don't want you to be stream i don't
want you to go from this to this right
center okay all right well john wayne it
is
i'll channel my energon lane
since the dogs go out of control
wherever visitors show up
scene one takes place at the front door
what you're doing right now is holding
back
and that only creates this right that
excitement that you have going on
intensify it right so you're gonna come
to the door i'm gonna knock the door and
do normal stuff and
you know and what do i do well instead
of the whole back you have to touch
hey okay door exercise one take one
case all right joe weinstein we'll see
don't tell me no we'll see what the dogs
do i know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
channel my inna john wayne
it's already been channeled
actually she was not supposed to jump
out of this she's like
sprung yes so can we do it again yep the
shot that i want to
have is for you to control this dog
from the couch uh-huh without the dog
ever coming out of the couch right
all right door exercise one take two
relax that's right that's very good
relax it's really nice
there we go come on sit tall
there we go how does that feel it feels
good
yeah now the exercise that i want to do
now
is for her to stay right there without
her jumping you know you're sitting down
hey do exercise one take three
hey it's very nice
very nice not bad for three times yeah
there you go
exterior mike's house day caesar
prepares to show mike how to correct his
dog's outside issues with the help
of two extras skateboarder one played by
andre milan
and skateboarder two played by calvin
milan
skateboard exercises take one all right
andre
i wanna see just can you go that way
yeah sure yeah
we're gonna study how he you know
control the situation
right now this is a good good behavior
on the other side andre
and the other side watch out there you
go good correction
hey that was also correction that was
great come here
stay right there now when you see a dog
on that side you can't go
on the same side of the dog you gotta go
on the other side
you understand yeah that's your common
sense
a lot of times people ask what's the
best way to protect my kid from a dog
when we are the person on the skateboard
instead they keep coming in the
direction of a dog
go in the other direction where is away
from the human
you know that just let the dog know that
you're not trying to claim
his side that's much better much better
see now that my son moved to the other
side the dog felt more respected by
my the kid and the skateboard coming
towards them that can help the handler
and the dog
to control the situation a lot better
okay all right calvin it's your turn
very good turn around okay now i'm gonna
tell you the same thing i told you
brother when you're coming on this path
and the dog is on this path you change
to the other side
where the human is the human is not
gonna bite the dog will
and if he's using the whole sidewalk you
stop
let animal pass you can also control the
situation
you understand can we do it again all
right go ahead
dogs don't mind sharing what they mine
is when do you come into their space
let's see if a calvin uh utilized very
good that's good
if you stand still that's good calvin
that's that's even that's also good so
again that
that it's not always the dog it's not
always the handler sometimes it's the
skateboard person who can control the
situation
stainless steel stops the chasing it
stops the prey drive
there you go there you go oh that's a
good one there you go correct that
go back again that's actually what i'm
looking for see the eye like that that's
not a very good state
i focus on showing mike how important is
to see low level of intensity
pay attention to body language lowering
the head
the ears forward that right there
watch this hey i prevent red zone i
prevent
super insecurity i prevent super panic i
prevent
and that's how i keep a dog closer to a
balanced state
at this point we have to be a little bit
more intense with the discipline
right with the discipline because
they're doing this
right
good girl good girl
we go good job good reaction that was
good that was good
oh that's okay come on control don't
worry about it just it's correct
hey yeah very good
that's why i'm doing it
right there very good you start
seeing slowly how mike start
understanding what discipline means
you know we know he's a great writer we
know he's a great good director
and we know he's a good actor so he has
all those elements to writing his own
movie we um i think we've made a lot of
headway with tootsie and ginger and more
importantly with me
seeing you do it with them makes me
realize that they can do it yeah it's
just
just telling it's just a matter of
handling yeah you realize that like if
you just
know a few basic things to look out for
that you can really
have a huge effect on your dogs i love
when i can teach
basic common sense if you have a pack of
dogs if you have a family your pack
leader
you have no choice very good correct
very good
that's just what you need to be for the
benefit of the environment
what do you think about discipline now
the dogs are happier
and i'm happier and certainly the kid
passing by
you have a lot of homework yeah i do
maybe the next movie
yeah exactly what is it going to be
about
i don't know but it'll it probably won't
be about wild untamed dogs like the last
one
cut print that's a wrap
when you have problems with your dog you
don't have to call in the marines
you can start by calling up some calm
assertive energy
pinky is no longer afraid of drone
contraptions
and she takes a few steps and her little
vehicles three times a week
they are taking things slowly so binky
won't get too tired or sore
with her new form of exercise according
to brazil kiko is doing much
much better he has improved dramatically
he's doing a lot more physical activity
like running on the treadmill twice a
day
and rollerblading way to roll
i am happy to report that my girls
ginger and tootsie are behaving on walks
and in the house more importantly mike
has now become their commissary director
which we need in hollywood thank you dog
whisper
it's all good in the next time remember
that in life you need to be the director
of the movie
the stars you and your dog
you